alors ça vous pendait au nez christophe
lambert va faire une interview anti
héros est-ce que vous avez déjà insulté
une petite vieille au volant j'avais moi
jamais non je te jure est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà barré avant que le
conseil se réveille
ouais et le problème c'est si elle se
réveille avant que tu sois varie pas
toujours mis mes questions et souvent
exactement exactement
donc ouais c'est écrit j'ai essayé mais
c'était il ya longtemps mais tu te
rappelles est ce que vous vous êtes
c'était génial parce que j'ai en
harmonie les conseillers en ai dit quoi
chez tout le monde en parle je conseille
des cartes non en fait tu dois lui plus
qu'un bon signe en invité alors la carte
non ben jelloun a passé l'âge et fils de
[ __ ] mais j'ai l'autre
attention continue l'interview anti
héros est ce que vous vous êtes déjà
excusé pour éviter de prendre un pain
dans la gueule
non non un succès l'interview non non
j'ai toujours essayé je pense que les
bagarres les points ne sont jamais des
solutions donc j'ai toujours essayé
d'éviter avant que cela arrive
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut s'excuser
non parce que moi je ne suis fait trop
tard suivant preuve ce que vous avez
déjà commandé un appareil de muscu au
téléachat en pensant que ça allait
changer votre vie non pas au téléachat
par contre j'ai une petite salle de gym
que j'utilise à peu près une fois tous
les deux ans seront qu'elle est pas très
viril
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé de
masquer un bouton avec du maquillage
bois est-ce que vous avez déjà fait la
bise à quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez non
est-ce que vous avez déjà quitté une
fille parce qu elle avait grossi non
plus mais j'ai jamais été avec des
grosses est ce que vous vous êtes déjà
barré avant de payer agissions pour les
abeilles et les autres jamais vous ai
déjà réclamé des fringues gratuite en
disant que c'était pour la télé si je
les ai réclamé pour l'atc parce que j
allais mais généralement je les rangs
après vous avez déjà citer un auteur en
laissant croire que c'est êtes-vous
allons vous avez fait des promesses de
dons une association vous n'êtes pas
tenu leurs comme vous avez déjà dit refi
que c'était la femme de votre vie pour
la sauter plus vite
non je te jure non j'aurais fait la même
interview darmon à ginola j'aurais que
des oui non mais parce que oui et on va
voir sur la suivante vous avez déjà
essayé de mesurer la taille de votre
pays or jamais
là franchement je veux dire il lui bon
il la mesure est moi j'y ai pensé mais
je n'ai jamais fait pourquoi des
résultats d'abord je vais te dire il
faut admettre
je m'explique
c'est rare de trouver des règles de
trois centimètres et dans les rajouter
boutabout tu vois ce que je veux dire
non tu prends un mètre et puis tu
mesures ça voudra dire car à mettre non
bon bah voilà ce qu'il a dit à mots
couverts qu'il avait une butte de 3 cm
j'ai pas que c'est ça qui l'a dit david
bien moi on en a déjà marre que jamais
les jeunes mutins il est coincé
il est coincé il est coincé ginola
pourquoi ça fait 20 ans que vous êtes
avec coraline est justement je sais que
ça fait 20 ans qu'on a nos commente ces
choses ce soir
1 tu gâches alors bon finalement vous
êtes pas d'anti héros est un vrai héros
ici parce que vous répondez non à toutes
les questions souffle habite encore
cedar manque a dit oui à votre place est
un antihéros c'est un vrai héros 1
est-ce que c'est en fin de compte un mec
qui a l'humilité ne veut pas à prendre
sur lui l'héroïsme de son axe c'est à
dire il part discrètement sans dire que
c'est lui qui a fait quoi que ce soit
c'est ça héros juste ouais ça lui va
bien d'avoir arrêté de picoler à lui
avant dernier dernière question est ce
que vous avez déjà utilisé du viagra
non mais j'ai souvent pensé comme ça
essayez pour voir ce que ça fait vous
n'avez jamais ce qu'on emballe j'ai pas
encore besoin mais c'est une question de
besoin les gens le prennent pour des
raisons créatives vous savez non mais
ouais mais pourquoi tu veut le prendre
si t'as pas besoin d'être encore
meilleurs christ
ouais mais bon si tu veux moi je suis
très bien avec ma petite femme
oui et ça va très bien sans lui à gr il
sait qu'on n'en prendre quand elle n'est
pas là
voilà on s'est embrouillé créés contre
par contre n'ont par contre c'est un
truc que j'essayerai way avec elle et
auxquels je pense moins souvent mais de
temps en temps la crème de marrons
chantilly où c'est le fantasme
la raison qu'est ce qu'il dit la crème
de marrons la chantilly le truc alors
j'ai compris j'ai compris mais le viagra
je n'ai pas essayé we say yeah
j'essaierai un jour aux jeux pour le
moment pas seulement quand j'en aurai
besoin voilà c'est ce que je voulais
entendre dire je vais comme gérard pour
des raisons récréative le viagra c'est
par un problème du tout que c'est bien
c'est pas malheureusement et du désir un
oui mais ça fait la led moins fraîche un
tic-tac témoins pourquoi tu me suces
alors avec l'otage bruce willis vous
redevenez un héros donc on va faire une
interview anti héros
[Musique]
bruce willis est ce que vous avez déjà
fermer votre gueule devant un flic qui
vous coller un pv ouais est-ce que vous
avez déjà fermer votre gueule devant un
flic qui s'en prenait à un black a alors
corps excuse moi le chèque bruce willis
hockey
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black
ah non et devant un blague qui s'en
prenait à un flux est ce que vous avez
déjà fait semblant de ne pas entendre
quelqu'un qui vous avait insulté alors
oui vous êtes déjà évanoui
on va voir parce que nous ça nous
arrange vachement que ce soit un anti
héros quand est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des chaussettes trouées par
exemple oui et des slips salle non
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé un
cascadeur pour une scène pourtant sans
danger
ah non vous avez déjà demandé à des
techniciens de sortir du plateau au
moment où vous alliez vous mettre tout
nu vous ai déjà eu une panne sexuelle
avec une femme très entreprenante à sète
hérault
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez et qui sortait des toilettes
sans salle à belem est ce que vous êtes
déjà barré avant qu'une de vos conquêtes
ne se réveillent financement dû et doit
céder cole le matin est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour coucher plus vite avec elle j'ai ce
n'est déjà profité qu'une fille soit
bourré pour coucher avec ap
oui voilà bruce willis
âgé d'à peine
c'est un vrai héros dans une interview
anti héros alors vigo est ce que vous
avez déjà renvoyé une fille chez elle
parce que finalement n'était pas assez
jolie j'ai
je pense que tous les filles sont jolies
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait un enfant
à une femme sans le reconnaître je crois
pas est-ce que vous avez déjà lâché les
chiens sur quelqu'un plutôt que d'y
aller vous même est ce que vous êtes
déjà fait semblant de ne pas entendre
quand quelqu'un vous traitez de petites
[ __ ] fait son âge pas de problème
avec ça
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé un
cascadeur pour des scènes sans danger
ces scènes de sexe par exemple je peux
vous dire que toutes les cascades dans
et suave annoncé vigo lui même qui
disent à tourner est-ce que vous avez
déjà demandé les techniciens de sortir
du plateau quand vous alliez vous mettre
tout nu non je crois pas
est ce que faisait déjà promis à votre
maîtresse que vous alliez quitter votre
femme en sachant que vous le feriez pas
bien vincent cassel qui est effondrée
parler assez de mes choses privées
vraiment est ce que vous êtes déjà piqué
la femme d'un de vos potes c'est moins
grave si c'est humble c'est vrai est ce
que vous êtes déjà barré avant qu'une de
vos conquêtes ne se réveillent jamais il
est bien c'est un vrai héros un menteur
on s'est vraiment hauteur mais est-ce
que vous avez déjà essayé de maquiller
un bouton et vous quand j'étais petit
oui quand j'avais 14 ans j'avais vu à
clé et je l'étais du pied rajhi et ses
théories parce qu'évidemment pas tombé
du clearasil sur un bouton on voit plus
que ça il a jamais eues avec les
limitations
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez pas complètement est-ce que
vous avez déjà laissé payer une femme au
restaurant
ouais est-ce que vous avez déjà citer un
auteur en laissant croire que c'était de
vous non je crois quoi est-ce que vous
avez déjà dit à une fille que c'était la
femme de votre vie
pour faire plus vite l'amour avec elle
il est honnête je trouve ce type
formidable il dit la vérité il est
honnête une extraordinaire voilà est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait virer un acteur
sur un tournage
non j'ai pas ce pouvoir si je l'avais je
n'utiliserai pas ouais
est ce que vous êtes déjà repris un
cadeau à une de vos ex
est-ce que vous avez déjà couché avec
une fille qui avait beaucoup trop bu
bigot et remember peut-être viggo
mortensen un juge
et
[Musique]